uh our next speaker is someone i first
met in the fall of 1994 after i arrived
in claremont california for graduate
school
and at the time he was working at the
claremont institute
um i was just a rube from the midwest
and
he was one of the first people i met at
the institute
i wasn't exactly sure then what a think
tank was
but i was in awe of anyone who got paid
to think all day
though he was based in sacramento i
would see him when he came to visit
the home office in claremont and we had
many fun and interesting conversations
usually over lunch at walters or over a
drink after work
we probably had too many of those and
two things have stuck with me about that
time one is that
i was a nobody and he was important but
he was always friendly and he always
took the time
to talk to me the other thing that has
stuck with me is
his ability well how i was impressed by
his ability to see right to the heart of
the matter
under discussion whatever the matter was
and
how he would clarify it for the rest of
us
and i suspect his ability had something
to do with the fact that he was a
student
of the late great professor harold rood
professor rude taught his students to
see past the surface of things and look
to
the heart of things well today he's the
president of the american strategy group
whose mission is to understand to see
past the surface of things and to
understand the strategic threats to the
united states
he's also a board member and a senior
fellow of the claremont institute
where he served as president from 2002
to 2015
and during his 25 years at the clermont
institute he directed its golden state
center in sacramento the national
security project
and he served as publisher of the
claremont review of books
he is currently chairman of the
committee on the present danger
china and is a member of the independent
working group
on missile defense he's the author of
communist china's war inside america
and his articles have appeared in many
places including among
others in primus he's a regular on the
bill bennett show podcast
he was a national security surrogate for
donald trump at the 2016
republican national convention he is a
native californian
and he's a graduate of claremont mckenna
college he's going to speak today about
america's top national security
concern please welcome to the podium
brian t kennedy
[Applause]
thanks tim well good afternoon
thank you for that kind introduction tim
tim is one of those people as you all
know that's very easy to be nice to
and you can see almost immediately a
person with a great intellect
who loves his country and so when he was
a young man it was easy to be
nice to tim it was a good investment
it's great to be with all of you today
and it's great to be in the free state
of south dakota
i thought governor gnome was spectacular
i think she has a real future ahead of
her
now anything intelligent i may have to
say today
will no doubt be in part due to my long
association
with two of hillsdale college's senior
people
my old friend larry yarn and doug
jeffrey
who were my colleagues for so many years
at the claremont institute
i'm very proud of all they've achieved
here at hillsdale college
and it's great to be with them here as
well
as tim mentioned i am chairman of the
committee on the present danger
china it was begun last year with my
friends and colleagues steve bannon and
frank gaffney
our purpose was to go around the country
and to explain to americans the threat
that communist china presents
to the united states and the free world
as i say we do that around the country
when we meet in washington dc
we meet at hillsdale college's kirby
center
let me offer you this afternoon this
proposition
we are today in a war and we run the
risk of losing
that war we are losing because too few
of us know
that we are engaged with an enemy the
chinese communist party
that means to destroy us to the extent
that this war is being fought
at all today it is by one man
president donald trump who has a resolve
to stand up to communist china
nearly all alone the forces of globalism
that have dominated the united states
for the better part of a half century
have blinded america's elites to the
threat before us
and that if we do not wake up soon as a
nation
we will find ourselves in a position
where we are both undefended
and unwilling to fight to be sure that
is a worst case scenario
and we are americans we're not going to
let that happen
but the forces arrayed against us are
many
we need to know what we are up against
and what steps must be taken
to ensure our victory let me describe
three things for you about china and the
chinese communist party
first who they are second what they are
capable of
and finally the war they are waging
against us
our modern understanding of communist
china begins with the cold war
and the strategic belief by richard
nixon
that china could be played against the
soviet union
a kind of counterweight what he called
the china card
as strategic ideas go this had many
benefits
we wouldn't have to take on the soviet
union all by ourselves
the prc was a populist country that
boarded the soviet union
and that we would both have a similar
desire
to check the soviet union's global
ambitions
even more so since we thought at the
time
communism was destined for the dustbin
of history anyway
and so getting rid of the communist
soviet union must ultimately
lead as well to the end of communism
as a guiding force in china now to
achieve these ends
we would engage in trade with communist
china and help them develop economically
and militarily we would transfer to them
our technological know-how
and eventually grant china most favored
nation status
american industry liked this idea they
saw opportunities economically
with a free and open china as a
commercial republic we here in the
united states thought this made perfect
sense
and as we all know the united states won
the cold war
and we believed ourselves the preeminent
military power on earth
the attacks on september 11th caused by
terrorists animated by a radical islamic
ideology
reinforced the notion however vicious
that day was
that superpower conflict was a thing of
the past
the best strategic and military thinkers
in america
were engaged now in fighting a war
against radical islam in iraq and
afghanistan
and other places in the middle east
grand strategic thinking of the kind
necessary to deal with great power
conflicts that might happen
with russia or china were largely
ignored
the so-called pivot to asia under
president obama
was mostly rhetorical if it meant
anything it was an effort by american
policy makers
to justify new ways of degrading our
military capabilities
vis-a-vis communist china prioritizing
the what we've termed endless wars in
the middle east
over anything else and allowing the prc
and the u.s economies to integrate
further
much as they had during the cold war
there was
you might say a kind of china dream that
despite their communist
ideology and with enough exposure to the
united states in the free world
china would become just like us
economic liberalism would lead to
political liberalism
and china's communist dictatorship would
eventually
fade away at minimum
americans thought a china that was open
to the united states would focus on
economic issues
rather than anything that might approach
superpower conflict of the kind we had
seen
with the soviet union now u.s policy
makers took it almost as an article of
faith
that this would happen because
if they got this wrong it would be
extremely costly
the u.s had not over this period of time
built a military that could challenge
the prc's aggression in the pacific
namely they began to build a modern navy
and they constructed military
installations in the south china sea
and the united states has supported the
rise of communist china
while allowing the export of our
manufacturing base
to china and elsewhere
now i believe history will record that
the so-called china card
was was and will prove to be very costly
costly because it could only have been
played with a great deal of
self-deception
about the nature of the chinese
communist party and the men who were
running it
economic liberalism did not lead to
political liberalism
and china's communist party far from
fading away
has mastered the governance of 1.4
billion people
how powerful you might ask is chinese
military and economic power today
as i say they have a population of 1.4
billion people
they are governed by a chinese communist
party that has 90 million
members and i estimate an additional 300
million
chinese that are deeply invested in the
success
of the regime combine that as more
people than we have
in the united states
they may not all believe in every single
aspect of what they call socialism
with chinese characteristics what
amounts to an ad mixture of maoism
marxism
and leninism that is practiced there
today
they may not all believe that but to
believe that they are
something other than active supporters
of the regime
would be wrong indeed communism
works very well for the chinese elite
for this group it is more akin to a kind
of fascism
where they retain effective control of
certain property
engage and engage in the kind of
public-private partnerships
where businesses in china are privately
run
with active participation by the chinese
government
in effect being run by the chinese
communist party
once a business reaches a certain size
in china
they will take on board a small cadre of
chinese communist party members
who serve as a direct liaison between
the business
and the government now however
inefficient this may sound at first
we are talking about a chinese communist
party that operates a massive
global intelligence network through
their ministry of state security
this network does their part if at all
possible
to assist chinese industry and
businesses through industrial espionage
cyber warfare and economic coercion
this type of state capital capitalism
what you might call
a kind of neo-mercantilism has led to
the creation of a modern economy
that rivals that of the united states we
might like to believe that communism in
china
because of its inherent contradictions
cannot be sustained and will lead to the
collapse of the regime
and it may well someday but the chinese
communist party has proven extremely
capable
in building an empire that can govern
1.4
billion people that required the
conquest of a large number of people
in china who are not willing to be
subjugated
it required the physical mastery of a
territory
not easily managed given the perennial
challenges of flooding
witness what is happening today with the
three gorgeous dam
and other physical limitations
that they have done all this in such a
short period of time
and in such a ruthless and determined
way should give
those in america and the west pause
theirs is an achievement unparalleled in
the known history
of the world today they have
a military of two million men
under arms including the largest navy in
the world
they may not be qualitatively on par
with the united states
but it is said that quantity has
equality all its own
in the last five years of us naval war
games
where the united states has pitted
against the people's
liberation army navy and these are
u.s war games where we simulate
ourselves
conflict between china and the united
states
for the last five years during those war
games
each and every time we have not been
victorious
these are of course our war games we
have our best
military minds knowing what we have to
work with
and what we're up against they realize
that we simply do not have enough ships
and munitions to defeat the chinese navy
absent the use of strategic nuclear
weapons
the prospects of which are dire to say
the least
well it might be said at least the
chinese do not have a nuclear
arsenal like ours here we don't know
really what the chinese actually possess
we know they are capable of building
nuclear weapons we know they have them
we know they're capable of building
advanced missiles and rocketry
and that they possess some quantity of
them
we know they stole or otherwise obtained
advanced u.s technology
when it came to warhead miniaturization
and guidance systems
they have had the industrial capacity
for the better part of two decades
to build these in quantities that can
challenge the united states
we have also the knowledge for our part
that we here in the united states have
not tested a nuclear warhead since 1992
and have not built the kind of advanced
arsenal
that might be required to deter the
communist chinese
we also know after all that the current
secretary of the chinese communist party
xi jinping
is an adherent to the beliefs of mao
tong
and that both mao and deng xiaoping
believed that the united states was a
paper tiger
that we had nuclear weapons but that we
weren't going to use them
there was also on the part of the
chinese the rather disturbing belief
on their part that even if we did use
them
we couldn't kill all of them
that's the way a nation at war thinks
as for the pla's air force they possess
and are building today advanced fighter
aircraft
that rival anything that the united
states has built
again they may not have the quantity but
that will come
with time as for proficiency
in warfighting that is something
likewise that can be acquired
for all of our military superiority
we have not been in actual combat with a
pure competitor
for a half century as good as we may be
the history of the world consists of
nations
who want to be on top who want to be
the best and they're not going to sit by
and let another nation
retain that superiority if they can
themselves achieve it
if we think that this is not exactly
what the people's liberation army is
seeking today
we are sorely mistaken
now i'd like to tell you that the
american military understands all this
and is prepared to engage and defeat
such an enemy
although there may be some who do still
it is a more widely held view and not
entirely unreasonable
that the us does not want to fight a
land war in asia
does not want to engage the prc in the
pacific
and does not want to engage in nuclear
war
and although we don't want to fight a
land war in asia
neither do we want a military that's
incapable
of deterring chinese aggression in the
pacific
such that we'll be unable to defend our
interests or that of our allies
now let me be clear we as a nation are
not looking for war with communist china
but unfortunately communist china may be
looking for war
with us there was a famous book by two
chinese colonels of the people's
liberation army
who published a book back in 1999 called
unrestricted warfare
it has become a popular document for i
and my colleagues to point to on the
committee on the present danger china
in this book these two colonels believe
that war between the u.s
and the prc is inevitable and when it
occurs the prc must be prepared
if they are to win to engage in whatever
means are necessary to achieve
victory now they write in the book
that the variable means to achieve this
include the use of economic warfare
cyber warfare information warfare
political warfare
terrorism bio warfare
and the like this is back in 1999.
their purpose in writing all of this was
to shape chinese policy
of course on the one hand but also to
lay down a
marker for u.s us policymakers that
nothing is out of bounds
when it comes to relations military
relations
between the prc and the united states
hence the title
unrestricted warfare
they want to make clear that not only is
the prc capable of waging
war but they are committed to doing
whatever it takes to win
now the very act of writing such a book
was itself an act of
information warfare
they believed themselves in writing it
that they could shape pentagon policy
planners
and try in their own way to discourage
them
from designing a military that was
capable of challenging the prc
because they knew if the united states
did not build a military capable of
challenging the prc
as in we don't have enough ships
nor enough planes nor national missile
defense
then we will just out of necessity have
to make some kind of accommodation
with the prc whatever that might be
this is what you call strategic planning
and this is what you call statecraft and
the chinese are very
good at it all of this is to say that
america got wrong that
china would abandon their communist
ideology
and have built a nation that now
presents a threat to the united states
which leads to the question what are
they capable of
now we need look no further than the
history of the chinese communist party
estimates put the number of dead at the
hands of the ccp
at roughly 100 million either through
war
starvation or execution
the mass murder committed by the chinese
communist party and their red guards
during the
great leap forward and the cultural
revolution
alone saw the death of some 70 million
people
that they believed were necessary to
remake china
into the country we see today
now this itself does not count the
forced abortions that resulted from the
prc's one-child policy
that number is put at conservatively 500
million children who were murdered
500 million
for everyone in the high-tech world
who often point to china as this example
of
economic development that they're able
to move so quickly and
so effortlessly effortlessly to develop
new industries
i find the contrast with that number of
forced abortions
horrific these are not people who share
the aspirations of western civilization
freedom and the sanctity of human life
are not things that they hold dear
they are today perfecting a system of
social credit scoring
that monitors the social media of their
people and grades them based on their
support of the regime
there is a chilling effect on the people
of china
who have seemed to have made a choice to
go along and get along with their
communist masters
lest they be excluded from whatever
benefits they could enjoy
from china's push toward economic
modernization
and at one level one can hardly blame
them
for going along and getting along
we see today the imprisonment of muslims
in xinjiang province
and the lengths to which the regime has
gone to segregate
one to two million uyghurs and put them
in concentration camps
one might call them re-education camps
but it is difficult to see what
re-education they are actually receiving
when pressed on the subject the chinese
government will call them
vocational training camps but given the
numbers it is difficult to keep what is
going on
their secret the chinese government
among other atrocities
facilitates the rape and abduction of
uyghur women
for use by chinese soldiers even worse
if that were possible they actively
engage
in organ harvesting of the uyghur
population
and sell their organs both in china and
abroad
this has become a multi-billion dollar
industry
it's difficult to know how widespread
knowledge of this is
is within communist china but it's an
amazing incentive to keep your head down
and behave yourself and not speak
against the regime lest you
to be sent to a re-education camp
this is what politics looks like in a
communist nation
how this atrocity of organ harvesting
does not occupy the consciousness
of every sentient human being is beyond
belief
the ability to look the other way could
not be illustrated any clearer
than the new disney movie called mulan
in it there are several scenes where the
backdrop in the movie
was in fact the same uyghur detention
camps
that were hiding in plain sight an
american audience would not know what
they were looking at
but a chinese audience most likely would
the chinese must have been struck by the
wanton disregard
american filmmakers had for these weaker
camps
wall street investors themselves
arbiters
of all things moral and american society
most especially environmental concerns
seem not to have a problem with the
imprisonment of uyghurs
they have seemed to have no problem with
china's atrocious environmental record
as well other examples worth noting
in southern mongolia the ccp is working
to eradicate their native language
lest they be capable of passing on their
traditions folkways
and familial bonds of affection
and in chinese schools there are now
textbooks with a history of christianity
that distorts what the bible says and
the teachings of jesus
in the chinese retelling jesus was not
only a sinner
but when presented with the passage of
the woman
who was about to be stoned for adultery
in the chinese version version it was
jesus who stoned her to death
dr aaron earlier was talking about
controlling people's minds
that is what is going on in china
despite this pope francis will renew his
agreement with the chinese
communist party to give them effectively
control
over how the catholic church or what
passes for it
operates in china now it's worth noting
these levels of depravity
and human rights abuses both because it
needs to be said
and because it illustrates what they are
capable of doing to their own people
and therefore by extension what they are
capable of doing
to other people if they have the
opportunity
namely us of course the chinese
communist party operates a vast
intelligence network
in the united states as well it is made
up
not merely of chinese intelligence
operatives
working for the ministry of state
security but they also have
here in this country 700 370 000
chinese students attending american
universities
they have confucius institutes operating
on american campuses
they have the chinese students and
scholars association
in a myriad of business and business and
industry officials
all of them from the students on down
who are subject to the prc's national
intelligence law of 2017 specifically
article 7 which requires that any
citizen
shall support assist and cooperate with
the state
intelligence network
students in american universities have
to report to handlers in chinese
consulates and embassies
about who they meet the research work
that they have going on
and give to the chinese government
whatever information is asked for
quite literally the national
intelligence law touches the lives
of every single chinese national that
comes to the united states
it's not surprising that a combination
of this network
and cyber theft could yield five to six
hundred billion
a year of intellectual property theft
they also have operating here in this
country the thousand talents program
run by the chinese communist party that
seeks to hire the best and brightest
chinese and american professionals to
work with growing
chinese industry and scientists
this has been an especially problematic
program for the united states
witnessed the arrest of harvard
professor charles lieber earlier this
year
for not disclosing his ties to the
chinese government he was
doing some important research for the u
s government
but it turns out also for the chinese
government
recently there was fired in my home
state of california
a chinese american who was the cfo
of the california public employment
retirement system
his name was you ben ming he had been
responsible for investing calpers funds
in chinese corporations tied to the
people's liberation army
and into chinese companies that he
himself was personally invested in
so here is a guy
chinese national moves to the united
states becomes
an american citizen goes to american
universities
works in american financial
for american financial corporations
and then gets hired by the chinese to
come work in china
where he does for three or four years he
then comes back to the united states and
is hired to be the
chief financial officer of a major
major investment firm in this country
could there be any tie between chinese
intelligence
and their desires and such a program
in my own work it seems to me that that
one of the greatest threats we face
is from china corrupting america's
business
and financial elites who see economic
opportunity
and put it before america's interest if
there is a single group committed to the
success of the globalist project
and what i previously referred to as the
china dream it is wall street
it is not surprising although most
disappointing that the single most
influential group opposed to
america first national security and
economic policy policies
are the leaders of our financial
community who see money to be made by
integrating
the u.s and chinese economies
all of which might lead you to ask what
does this mean for the united states
i said at the outset that we were at war
with the people's republic
of china we are in this war because
donald trump had the temerity
what all of us would call courage to
declare to a candid world that he was
going to put the interests of america
first and in the economic war the prc
was waging
against the united states as i say over
the past decade almost six
trillion dollars of american wealth have
been stolen
by the prc through their theft of
intellectual property
the united states with the tech
innovations coming out of silicon valley
in seattle
with entertainment coming out of
hollywood with the medical research and
development centers in new england and
elsewhere
to name just a few industries was
witnessing theft
at an unimaginable scale
properly understood this is the wealth
and future wealth of the american people
that the chinese communist party was
stealing
now ironically this intellectual
property was mostly being produced in
the very places
most hostile to president trump
politically
california washington new york
massachusetts but president trump staked
his presidency
on holding china to account because he
knew that the united states if it's
producing anything
is producing intellectual property
and he did it also let me just say
because it was the right thing to do
even more dangerous from the prc's point
of view president trump was well on his
way to establishing in the public mind
the nature of chinese economic
malfeasance
and that it ought to come to an end that
american policy makers ought to put
america first and that trade deals ought
to benefit
the american people rather than some
other nation
in addition president trump combined his
economic message
with a strategic military buildup when
he
announced the creation of a new branch
of our armed services
the united states space force this meant
the united states was not going to cede
the strategic high ground of space
to communist china from the chinese
point of view
no u.s president had ever had the
audacity
to do such a thing not merely was
president trump not transferring
technology to the prc
and making sure they would be punished
for stealing our intellectual property
he was also rebuilding the american
military in such a way
as to challenge communist china's
growing
military prowess it was almost as if the
chinese communist party was no longer
going to tolerate president trump's
america first policy
and so decided to take matters into
their own hands
mostly out of the public eye on may 13
2019 so last year the people's republic
of china through their state media
apparatus
xinhua news agency it's controlled by
the ccp
declared a people's war against the
united states
how many of you knew that they had
declared a people's war
it was in response to president trump's
imposing tariffs
because of their failure to negotiate in
good faith
on the theft of intellectual property
and open their markets to u.s goods
their purpose a year before the u.s
presidential elections
was to alert the chinese people that war
was coming
that its form would be based on their
own communist
total war tactics of information war
political war economic war and even
quite possibly the use of military force
the second purpose of this declaration
of a people's war
was to warn the national security
apparatus of the united states
that whatever should follow ought to be
seen in this light lest anyone become
alarmed
and miscalculate their response now we
have to ask whether the use of the
phrase
a people's war was a throwaway line just
kind of like rhetoric they were angry
that day
or did it mean something did it signal
a fundamental shift in chinese thinking
now i would not go so far as to say that
the chinese china virus
that came from the wuhan institute of
virology was part of their people's war
but it did set into motion a radical
reorientation of american society
that appears almost entirely political
in its nature
we know a certainty that after the virus
began spreading
in what appears to be the fall of 2019
the earliest dates where the virus is
found traced back to november and
december
that the chinese closed down flights
from wuhan which is in hubei province
to the rest of china they allowed as we
know
flights to go from muhan to both europe
and the united states
they knew with certainty that the virus
would spread
as viruses do did their people's war
include the spread of covet 19 as an
intentional weapon against the united
states
locked down wuhan and presented to the
world the story of men
in hazmat suits trying to contain the
virus
stories of welding people's doors shut
so that they could not leave their homes
stories of otherwise healthy people
dying from the virus
and the general impression that we
americans
were supposed to receive
was that this was the most lethal and
contagious virus
we had ever seen the united states and
our center for disease control
which has an office in china asked to be
led into wuhan to investigate
to this very day we have been denied
access
the initial gene sequencing of the virus
that we received
evidence from dr fauci that china was
being open and cooperative
that gene sequencing was wrong a
critical detail that made testing
all the more difficult were these
political decisions by the chinese
government
was this part of their people's war if
you were the chinese communist party
and you were waging a people's war
against donald trump
do you have an interest in the year he
is to be re-elected
to have his countrymen believe they're
in the middle of the deadliest pandemic
in modern history do you have an
interest
in establishing in the public's mind
that the only method for dealing with
this virus
is a complete lockdown for some
indefinite period of time
the wearing of masks the relinquishing
of their personal freedoms
so that americans would not die by the
millions
might there be any consideration that
this would have a political impact
on president trump and his america first
policies
when challenged on all this that same
new service of the chinese communist
party xinhua news agency
threatened americans that they could
plunge us into quote
a mighty sea of coronavirus
since it was they the chinese who
controlled the supply chain for the
active pharmaceutical ingredients
used in the production of 90 of our
medicines
this fact alone that our medicines are
made
at this level in china and only china
some in india of course but not in the
united states
this fact alone is a scandal of immense
proportions
that president trump is today trying to
correct
although downplayed by the american
media it was significant that president
trump closed the borders
to china but no sooner had he done that
that that same news agency xinhua news
and also the global times another organ
of the chinese communist party
had a major push in the media
globally but also here in the united
states to reopen the border
again they knew how contagious the virus
was
and spent money and resources to see if
they couldn't get us to reopen
our borders now whether or not the wuhan
virus was a byproduct of biological
weapons research
or inadequate safeguards in a virology
lab
it is the chinese communist party that
is to blame for its
spread throughout the world and it is
criminal
in its conduct to have kept the world in
the dark
about the nature of the pathogen and it
will be criminal if we do not hold them
to account
for what they have done to the united
states
but you might say this is just part of
the people's war
that they had warned us that such a
thing could happen
but to talk this way in washington is
nearly unheard of
what else has happened in this people's
war it will come as a surprise to no one
that
communist china uses its diplomatic
mission in countries around the world as
a base for industrial espionage of the
kind i've described
and to conduct political and information
warfare
in the united states of course it's no
different
on july 24th of this year so not that
long ago
the u.s state department closed down the
chinese consulate in houston
because it served as a hub for chinese
communist party operatives
who were engaging in the attempted theft
of america's
research into among other things the
development of a vaccine
for cobit 19. the u.s closed the
consulate
also because to quote a u.s state
department official
quote consulates are also bases of
operation
for fox hunt teams he said these are
teams of agents
sent from china here to coerce economic
fugitives
meaning political rivals of president xi
the communist party critics and refugees
coercing them
that is to return to the prc
consulates enable the activities of
those teams this is the u.s government
talking now
consulates also enabled direct lobbying
of state and local officials
as well as business people to favor
chinese interests
and while that's to be expected by
diplomats
when it takes a turn toward the coercive
or the covert
that becomes a national security problem
end of quote what does that mean
so the chinese communist party sends
non-diplomats
essentially intelligence operatives to
the united states
to intimidate lobby and coerce
americans now although not part of the
acknowledgement of the closure
it was also widely believed that chinese
operatives in the houston consulate
may have given intelligence to black
lives matter and nt for rioters
during the riots in houston as a way of
demonstrating their solidarity
with their communist allies again we're
talking about their people's war
and it's a well-accepted belief among
communists
that there is a middle-class aversion to
violence
it would not be inconsistent for the ccp
and their foot soldiers
in blm and antifa to believe that
america can be cowed
into staying at home and keeping their
heads down
and supplicate themselves literally and
figuratively
to the notion that they are racist
deserve to be beaten
and have their way of life destroyed
given their earlier pronouncements about
unrestricted warfare
and all that could entail it would be
unrealistic to dismiss such actions
as outside the realm of possibility
indeed there is growing evidence that
the chinese communist party is employing
a kind of united front strategy using
their ideological allies black lives
matter
antifa and without being too political
i would say the democrat party it
appears that funding for blm and antifa
is coming from the communist
chinese-sponsored
or affiliated groups called liberation
road
the freedom road socialist organization
and the chinese progressive association
if the chinese are in a war a people's
war as they have proclaimed
we need to take them at their word and
address this much more seriously
as a nation than we have
let me say in conclusion that in the
middle of the civil war
we find ourselves in today it should not
be a surprise that the enemies of
freedom have taken the side of the
communists
and insurrectionists who mean to destroy
our republic
it's not that difficult to see the
demonic forces
that have been unleashed upon the world
and our country
but they do not understand the
resilience and determination
of the american people to defend our
liberty
and our constitutional order as free
men and women let us be prepared to do
our part
to defend the american way of life as
children of light let us be an example
to our countrymen about all that is good
about american civilization now and in
the days ahead
thank you
thank you mr kennedy we now have some
time for q a
if you have a question please make your
way to one of the microphones and the
side aisles
question on the speakers right one of
the hottest
stocks this past year has been zoom and
i've heard that they've been coerced by
china to close some accounts how
independent
is zoom from china they like the rest of
the country
are subject to that national
intelligence law
and are required under chinese law to be
able to give
anything that the chinese intelligence
service
asked for we know that the
source code of zoom goes through
i believe both beijing and shanghai and
so we would have to assume
that if the chinese government wanted to
look into any zoom call
that they legally would have the power
to do so
and so that would not be a great option
would they have an interest in being
one of the controllers of zoom during
all this
given all the business that transpires
across zoom
sure we have a question on the speakers
left yes
we're being prepped chaos in the
post-election
period if i were going to attack taiwan
that's when i would do it is that
plausible
well there are some alarming moves that
china is making
vis-a-vis taiwan
i would expect in this post-election
period all sorts of chaos
and it looks here in this country like
there's going to be riots before during
and after the election
and during that period we're going to
focus an awful lot
on keeping our own country together it
will be difficult during that to
to monitor what goes on in taiwan
and so if anything could happen that
would be an opportune time for them
doesn't mean it will happen i think the
chinese would not be that interested in
leading us to that kind of a war but you
never know
and i think the the gist of what i'm
trying to convey today
is that these are people who are very
determined and if one of their goals was
to take back taiwan
they're going to try to do that whether
it's now or later
good question question on the speakers
right
uh thank you for the information that
you've been sharing so far
and i'm not certain how prevalent this
is but
an economics professor at hillsdale
shared with me that there are two
there are multiple factions but two of
the major ones right now in the chinese
communist party are the
communist youth league and the shanghai
faction
do you have any insight into which one
might be more ethical
or more cooperative with the west
no i mean the um
this is the so-called united front of
all these different groups within
communist china i am i don't believe
there's any scenario where
i don't think there's any useful
scenario where we can try to decide
whether there's good communist or bad
communist
in china they're communists they believe
a certain ideology they're ruthless
about it
and i think they're going to they'll
always have internal fighting within
communist china
but xi jinping has proven himself most
determined to
you know hold power and he's likely to
do that
i think it operates actually china more
like a mob
the chinese communist party does too
they'll have all these different foot
soldiers and all these different groups
but they're still the mob they're an
immoral
group of people who are you know
totalitarians at heart the real question
is whether or not freedom could ever be
brought to china
we know freedom is a very difficult
thing republican government is a very
difficult thing
and so china will develop as china
develops
my essential point is we americans need
to make sure we're strong
i don't speak chinese i never had any
interest in speaking chinese
i don't even find chinese society all
that interesting
what i care about is america and
defending this country and making sure
that we're strong
and free that's the thing we have to
care about
[Applause]
we have a question on the speaker's left
i yes uh mr kennedy um
recently there has been an immunologist
from hong kong
who uh who has escaped china
and come to the u.s who was very
involved
with working with the labs in wuhan
on the coronavirus and
has indicated she's been highlighted
several times on fox news
it has indicated that uh we're not
indicated she has stated
that it was intentional that the
coronavirus was released in order to
infect the u.s and many of its allies
your thoughts
i've seen her speak several times
several of my colleagues have
interviewed her
she seems pretty impressive and her
rendition of all that seems pretty
authoritative
and so i i would think
she's useful in listening to because she
does describe
some of the gain of function research
china was doing and so that gain of
function research
tries to take a virus and make it more
lethal
we think that kind of research here in
this country
is dangerous and so we outlaw it in this
country
dr fauci looks like farmed that kind of
research out
to china to do
itself utterly insane
at some level but her her explanation of
that sounds
very plausible to me but whether or not
that's actually true or not they
certainly exported it around the world
knowing how lethal it was
or how contagious it was and then as we
know
very lethal for people with certain
comorbidities
so yes no i i do think she's important
and worth listening to but
even if she's totally wrong the chinese
knew what they were doing
in letting the virus escape
thank you very much for your comments
and it's
very revealing what's going on in china
but we don't really know a lot the
center for security policy
and gordon chang have said that 40
million people
have been moved from the three gorgeous
dam area
and that there is great worry the three
gorgeous dam
may break probably because of
the pressure of a lot of rain plus bad
design
could you please comment yeah no i think
that's a very important thing one of our
um
one of the members of the committee jeff
nyquist has written about
the grand solar minimums that are
currently going on
and the fact that
rain right now in china is at a
historic level and
that amount of rain is putting an undue
burden
on their entire system for dealing with
floods
if the three gorges dam breaks then
that will be a horrific type of
incident in china and it looks to me
very possible that just the kind of
natural
disaster that we could see because of
these
you know very a very large rain season
in china could cause them very serious
problems
and so gordon chang is absolutely right
i work with frank gaffney and fred
flights at the center for security
policy on these things
and i think they're spot on on the
danger of all that
can you tell us a little bit about the
effect of falun gong
and their work to try to expose some of
the things going on in communist china
yes i mean i think they're they're one
of those groups that has managed to
organize
outside of communist china in order to
explain
just how the chinese communists think
i was struck earlier by by dr arne's
explanation
of totalitarianism and how
you know the kind of dramatic way
communists or totalitarians think the
epic times for instance which is a
publication of
falun gong related people
has an explanation for what's going on
today in china that i think is unrivaled
and they're doing some just outstanding
work
and explaining some of the evils of
communist china that
are not going to make their way into the
mainstream
media in any way shape or form
largely we americans are living our
lives we're trying to sort through a
whole host of things
including now the pandemic we tend not
to focus on things like
china they do and they've done some
some great work on that so that's a good
question
yes sir thank you for your presentation
i would like to know if you
feel there's a relationship between
george soros funding
of antifa as well as the cooperation
with china
i think soros is in his open society
foundation have been
funding all sorts of nefarious
activities including antifa
and blm and have been
active in the american political process
for some time
soros has been funding the election of
all these
secretaries of state around the country
and also these liberal
you know district attorneys so soros
does mean to play in a very extensive
way in american politics
antifa blm all of that has been
part and parcel of that soros in china
probably is a different matter
i don't think they work in concert but
both of them have
at their heart the destruction of the
united states
and so in that regard they they're a
formidable challenge to us
and we in this country have not done an
adequate job
in seeing soros or people like him as a
threat to our freedom
witness the fact that you know if
someone mentions soros on fox news
they'll be shouted down as speaker
gingrich did you know not that long ago
so yes i mean we we're living in a very
weird time in this country's history
where things that should be open and
transparent to the american people
are not so transparent and this is why
i would say hillsdale college is so
important
the pursuit of the truth what does it
take
to defend america the american way of
life
american civilization what does that
take
that is our job that is the job of free
people
who care about those things that matter
and thank hillsdale college for for
doing it
better than anybody else
please join me in thanking mr kennedy
[Applause]
you